he's been a fixture of every single big
screen Batman franchise but the
cinematic attempts that the Joker have
never really lined up with the version
that we see in the comics even when
their great performances with iconic
visuals
there's always something that the movies
get wrong we've all seen Thomas and
Martha Wayne get shot down in an alley
about 47 times so we all know that
superhero movies love to give their
viewers an origin story it's not just
for the good guys either almost every
villain who steps on to the screen
brings a whole back story with them
normally that's not a problem
and can actually give those villains the
pathos that makes for a compelling story
in the jokerz case however it's the
exact opposite the biggest offender in
this regard is of course Tim Burton's
1989 Batman film in which Jack Nicholson
took on the role of the Clown Prince of
Crime not only do we get a full origin
story his past gets tied back into
Batman's own origin so that we can wrap
everything up in a nice bow which
ultimately makes him less interesting we
see that he's a weird catchphrase
spewing homicidal maniac long before he
tumbles into a vat of acid the only real
difference aside from an admittedly
iconic look is that he gets slightly
more artistic with his murders for a
while it seemed like the movies had
learned their lesson on this front the
Joker that we saw in the Dark Knight
shows up fully formed and even offers
conflicting versions of his own origin
depending on who he's talking to know
what could be scarred
even more recently Jared Leto's version
and Suicide Squad is downright
inexplicable in pretty much every way
now though we have an entire movie about
the jokerz origin without any signs of
Batman set for release this year
hopefully this time they'll be able to
get rid of all that compelling mystery
that he's been burdened with for so long
fans have long accepted the idea that
it's Batman who's Bruce Wayne's true
identity and not the billionaire playboy
alter ego and it's a good rule of thumb
and yet the movies treat the Joker
someone who exists specifically in
response to Batman as someone who always
has to have that personal connection
admittedly they do this with most of the
villains is a little bit of origin story
short hand in the Joel Schumacher films
the Riddler and poison ivy are both
former employees of Wayne industries out
for revenge against their old boss The
Joker however exists specifically to be
a counterpoint to Batman the person
under the mask is basically irrelevant
compared to the ideological battle being
waged against the symbol that aspect of
the Joker's character however is
continually missed by the films in the
89 Batman it's not enough that the
Joker's trying to murder the entire city
with a cloud of poison gas there has to
be a personal connection to get the
crime fighter into action even in 2019 s
Joker solo film billed as being more of
a character study than a superhero flick
Thomas Wayne appears as an antagonist to
provide that connection yet again for
all its flaws the 89 Batman movie
incorporates one longtime definitive
element of the Joker that no other film
does it's the one that remembers his
trademark is poison
smile in the comics Joker toxin dates
back to the characters very first
appearance in 1940 and has been a
signature of the character ever since in
addition to the outright creepiness of a
corpse with a smile frozen on its face
there's nothing that captures the
Joker's mission statement quite as well
as leaving behind dead bodies in his own
image creating a world with more Joker's
for obvious reasons the campy
kid-friendly 1966 Batman film didn't
involve a lot of poisoned murders when
Heath Ledger offered up a performance
that defined a joker for a new
generation his weapons of choice were
knives explosives and complicated moral
dilemmas which left very few people
smiling The Suicide Squad Joker seems to
favor guns and knives as well which we
know from the scene where he's laying on
the floor in a weird circle of them that
also includes baby clothes champagne
bottles and a laptop it's definitely a
striking visual in its own right but it
gets a little less sinister once you
start imagining Jared Leto spending
hours arranging it all to get it just
right on one level you have to hand it
to the cinematic versions of the Joker
they always set their sights pretty big
in Batman 89 the Joker attempts to
poison the entirety of Gotham during the
city's Bicentennial using a deadly
parade
[Music]
those are my balloons in the dark night
he tries to trick a literal boatload of
citizens into blowing themselves up and
that's after a series of high-profile
murders in the bombing of a hospital the
Joker of suicide squad doesn't get much
screen time but it's already established
in Batman vs Superman that he killed
Robin even in the 60s version the
Joker's part of a plot to vaporize every
delegate of the United Nations at the
height of the Cold War of course this
isn't really a departure from the source
material since the 80s the Joker's body
count has been ramped up to the extreme
resulting in a character who's only
slightly less lethal than saved the
bubonic plague even his attempt to take
out the UN is something that would
eventually make its way into the comics
as part of the a death in the family
story even if it's always overshadowed
by Robin being killed the thing is
that's not the only thing that Joker
does while he has a long history of wild
theatrical murders the Joker is also
known for his unpredictability sometimes
he shows up in poisons everyone and
sometimes he applies for a patent on
smiling fish and only turns to murder
once he's denied sometimes he tries to
become the first criminal to commit
crimes on the moon a lot of those
stories might result from his decades
operating under the comics code but that
bizarre unpredictability is what makes
the Joker work as more than just a
slasher movie bad guy The Joker wasn't
the first over-the-top thematic crook to
show up on the comics page but if you're
looking for a place to draw the line
between villain and supervillain he
makes a good place to start
will they get a load of me
[Music]
his arrival in Batman number one set the
standard for costume criminals and
provided the blueprint that
supervillains are still using almost 80
years later more often than not though
movies treat the Joker as just a
slightly more colorful representative of
traditional organized crime while that
was true for his first few appearances
Joker became far more than that
in Batman 89 the Joker eventually winds
up in full-on supervillain mode complete
with an army of henchmen and matching
satin jackets but at heart Jack Napier
is a gangster and his first actions
after his transformation involved taking
over the mob the same goes for the Dark
Knight where the Joker's introduction
involves him taking a contract for the
murder of Batman eventually
destabilizing the city's organized crime
in order to sow chaos what people oppose
it's simple we kill the Suicide Squad
might actually be the film that goes
farthest showing the Joker as a mob boss
holding port in a nightclub that caters
to facial tattoo enthusiasts presumably
this is meant to tie the Joker to a more
realistic idea of crime which seems
pretty unnecessary our audience is only
going to accept a genocidal maniac who
has turned into a clown by falling into
a pit of chemicals who also fights a man
dressed up as a human size bat only if
we can relate him to The Sopranos this
is a weird thing to say about the Joker
but sometimes less is more since his
first live-action appearance in 1966 the
design for the Joker in live-action has
become more and more over-the-top from a
visual standpoint Jack Nicholson was a
more or less accurate recreation of what
we'd seen in the comics he fletcher
combined the traditional purple suit
with weird studiously sloppy face paint
and his infamous scars and jared leto
well you know the guy has damaged
tattooed on his forehead and that is an
aesthetic that doesn't even exist in the
same universe as the concept of subtlety
while that particular take on the Joker
is certainly memorable it's not nearly
as effective as the relatively
restrained Dark Knight version and not
even close to being as iconic as the
simpler Batman 89 style when there's too
much to focus on from a visual
standpoint that visual loses its meaning
and just be
a jumbled mess 2019 s Joker seems to be
heading back in a slightly more
restrained direction
Joaquin Phoenix is back to the painted
on clown makeup but with the colorful
purple suit that matches his comic-book
counterparts established tradition
pretty well from a structural standpoint
one of the biggest problems with the
movie versions of the Joker is more of a
problem with movies themselves they only
really use in once while he's certainly
great as a one-shot villain the Joker is
best used when he's a persistent threat
the idea that he's always out there able
to just stroll out of Arkham Asylum and
begin his next chaotic crime spree is a
really cool part of his character just
like it is for any comic book
supervillain you never know who's going
to make their shocking return or which
mastermind might be manipulating things
from behind the scenes in order to make
the hero's life a nightmare that's when
the Joker works best when his exit from
the story is more ambiguous than
definitive when no one finds the body
and when you know he'll be back for
another round
I think you and I are destined to do
this forever unfortunately with the very
recent exception of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe movies are meant to be more
self-contained having the Joker linger
in the background while a movie focused
on less popular and marketable villains
would make about as much sense as having
dark side cooling his heels off screen
while a c-list bad guy like Steppenwolf
fought the Justice League in their first
big-screen outing interestingly enough
there was a thought of doing this during
the Dark Knight trilogy The Joker
survives the events of the film and the
novelization for the Dark Knight Rises
even mentions that he is the last
remaining inmate of Arkham Asylum
unfortunately Heath Ledger's tragic
real-life death prevented any of those
plans from coming to fruition leaving
his performance as a singular take on
the Joker the Joker scary he has to be
right he's the ultimate creepy clown a
mass murderer plotting death behind a
smile an unpredictable foil for a hero
determined to stop him at almost any
cost in all honesty the movies have that
one down the scene in Batman 89 where
the Joker unwraps his face and then
shatters a mirror laughing while
stammering doctor tries to blame his
work on a tray full of rusty tools
that's still legitimately unsettling and
a high point of the film that said
there's one thing the Joker ought to be
funny it really shouldn't be that
difficult to pull off since horror and
comedy both rely on a punch of surprise
to get their reaction but it's been a
tricky balance for the movies to walk
the closest we've seen to nailing it is
once again Ledger's performance in The
Dark Knight
hi Ledger's Joker pulls off great
genuinely funny bits of comedy in his
performance without ever losing that
undercurrent of menace it's a necessary
element recasting Batman as the straight
man in an unintentional comedy
partnership that usually ends with
someone dead as for the others well
Nicholson's version wound up being more
weird than funny and led us well that
performance was hilarious but probably
not in a way that was intentional still
has to count for something right check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite heroes and villains are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Applause]
[Music]